the Supreme Court hears arguments today
in a major case that threatens the
multi-trillion dollar tech industry the
argument is over a federal law
protecting social media platforms from
lawsuits over online content that they
recommend to their users Jan Crawford
spoke with a mother who says she paid a
very high price indeed for the tech
Giants freedom
ten-year-old Nyla Anderson was always
smiling and that's her twin brother and
there she is as a baby she was Tawana
Anderson's only daughter she was the
life of my life
she was smart she was loving she was
caring
she was a shining star she was my
butterfly
she was everything
Nyla died in December 2021 after
attempting the so-called Blackout
Challenge which she had seen on Tick
Tock like other social media Outlets
tick tocks algorithms recommend videos
and other content to users Anderson said
that feature led to nyla's death they
are actually feeding into our children
they are sending on videos that they
never even searched before and Anderson
sued Tick-Tock and has found papers in a
separate case now before the Supreme
Court for the first time could hold
social media Outlets accountable for
some of the information and videos they
are recommending to users Tick Tock
declined a comment on the lawsuit the
social media companies say a 1996
federal law Shields them from liability
and that the modern internet would not
exist if companies couldn't sort and
recommend third-party content to users
Free Speech Advocates say social media
companies have rights similar to
newspapers deciding what articles to
publish people criticize social media
platforms today and they have the right
to criticize them but they don't have
the right to legally force them to
publish certain content to not recommend
other types of content and so on but for
Anderson and other grieving parents they
argue that has to change how many more
kids until they come to an end how many
more that's my question to them
how many more children
until this stops for CBS mornings I'm
Jan Crawford in Philadelphia
so there's a lot in that in that case
there uh and there are other related
cases you know uh if terrorist videos
are recommended to people there was a
case out in California where a federal
officer was murdered after a social
media platform connected two of the
criminals who committed the crime and
the question is should these tech
companies be platforms that are neutral
passive receivers of all this content
did they be held liable or liable when
they start suggesting it to making
connections uh making a PlayStation
algorithm right such an interesting time
because we know as adults we can be
influenced so you can only imagine as a
nine or ten year old which then becomes
how do you sort of police that because
children need the technology a lot of
times for school or what have you but
you almost have to the kids are growing
up so fast because you're addressing
things like suicide and sex and you know
at nine or ten because they're being
exposed to it via social media or
friends who have social access to social
media it's it's tough my heart goes out
to that other yeah and reaction to that
piece any parent that has lost a child
or any family member to social media are
the pressures of
um it's tough because you know my
daughter was talking about that in her
room the blackout Blackout Challenge
yeah and I remembered it because that
was something that kids were talking
about in elementary when we were younger
you know hold your breath and then
that's my pressure on your chest we had
a conversation with her and all I'm just
saying this because as parents we have
to be overly involved yeah we have to be
openly the tech companies making money
off the suggestion because they want to
keep you on the site the longer you're
there interacting the more money they
make right and so these lawsuits are
saying no well if you're going to push
this then you're going to be liable for
this that Tick Tock and Instagram and
some of these things will say is well
you're supposed to be 13 or you're
supposed to be 16. but obviously there's
ways around that